thousands of anti-government protesters  staged a sit-in  in front of a sports stadium in the  capital bangkok on monday  they were trying to stop parties from  registering there for february's  the reason for blocking the entrance is  we want political reform  first to set new standards for the next  election  and then an election  but the sit-in did not prevent parties  from registering  by the time protesters arrived at the  stadium some party representatives were  already inside  including officials from the governing  party  despite the failure of their blockade  there is little sign that the opposition  will stop protesting  their leaders are concerned that prime  minister yingluck shinawatra could win  at the polls  and that her brother taksin shinowat  would then return from exile and reclaim  power  he fled the country amid corruption  charges five years ago  the opposition claims that he is still  pulling the strings behind the scenes  they're vowing to end the toxin regime